today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink Escom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
so it's Thursday meaning we once again
have new unemployment numbers from last
week the numbers are not good 2.4
million more people filed for
unemployment benefits last week and this
in total now is starting to be
staggering just unconscionable numbers
when we total up the job losses from
these 9 or so weeks of coronavirus of
unemployment pandemic area era maybe
it's 10 weeks at this point something
like that we are now at 38 point six
million jobs lost if on February 1st
anybody had said my prediction is by
June 1st we will have lost 40 million
jobs which is what it will probably be
after we add another week or two of
numbers I don't think anybody would have
believed it now if you want to find some
kind of like it could be worse type of
thing in the numbers what we can point
to is at least the numbers are declining
each week in terms of new people losing
their jobs in early April each week we
had like more than 6 million people
filed for new unemployment benefits and
then by the end of April early May we
were at 4 million a week 3 million a
week and it sounds crazy but that number
is now down to only 2.4 million more
jobs lost last week so in a sense we're
seeing a decreased rate of people losing
their jobs but once again even with
these diminishing numbers by mid July we
could be at 50 million 50 million people
having lost their jobs now let's do a
little bit of context because this is
important when we talk about this the
total workforce before the pandemic hit
was estimated at 158 million people so
the country is 331 million people many
of those are children
any of those are retired people so the
active working labor force was believed
to be a hundred and fifty eight million
people so thirty-eight point six million
losing their jobs means that twenty four
point four call it twenty five percent
about a quarter of the American
workforce lost jobs during the corona
virus pandemic now we've got to adjust
those numbers a little bit one way a
little bit the other way one reality is
these are probably underestimates
because there are lots of people who
lost jobs but for one reason or another
didn't file unemployment benefits there
may be people who lost a job but they're
independently wealthy or have another
source of income or whatever and they
just decided I'm not going to go through
the hassle of filing unemployment that's
a small group of people you have a
larger group of people who would file an
unemployment claim except it's a what we
might call a marginal job or a job that
is under the table in which case you
wouldn't be able to file for
unemployment benefits and there is still
some fraction of people who have just
been struggling to get the claim in
because systems have been overloaded
unemployment is run at the state level
50 states 50 different systems some are
mostly phone some are online combination
of the two so in a sense these numbers
are probably too low now on the other
side of this there are people who lost
jobs early on but have found new jobs so
we have a cumulative total of 38 point
six million unemployment claims in the
last nine ten eleven weeks but some of
those people who lost their job in March
for example have found a new job we
don't know exactly what number that is
but there are businesses that have been
hiring delivery business based
businesses grocery stores places like
Amazon and others have been hiring so
some of the people that lost jobs have
found new jobs now what we can be sure
of is given this bad news the stock
market is gonna do really really well
today and I'm sort of kidding but we've
seen a stock market that's increasingly
divorced from the unemployment news now
as we've talked about before
stock markets often react to how the
news compares to expectations so these
new numbers of about two point forty
four million more people losing their
jobs last week
it's more or less in line with
expectation so it may not move the
market very very much so what we may
actually see really shake up the stock
market would be the numbers that we're
going to get about the second quarter in
total so q2 earnings and q2 GDP may be
numbers that really move the stock
market potentially down but maybe not so
first we've got earnings seasons how
much did companies make during the
second quarter and typically we get
those numbers for the second quarter
which is April May June around July 15th
we'll start to get earnings numbers from
companies and that may push the market
up it may pull the market down then we
will get GDP numbers even later on so
we'll get initial GDP estimates for the
second quarter on July 30th and then
we'll get more accurate second quarter
GDP estimates towards the end of August
so realize that we are not going to know
the full scope of what happened in this
quarter right now essentially until mid
to late August almost September in
practice there are predictions that we
could see a 20% GDP decline in q2 25%
one estimate said 35 percent that's
certainly on the very high end so this
is about suffering it's not about
politics but we can't ignore that
historically bad GDP numbers the worst
GDP numbers the country has ever seen
8 weeks before a presidential election
we will know the full scope of those
those numbers again late August that may
be very very bad for Donald Trump now
for now as states have been improving on
their coronavirus numbers and putting in
place plans to get some portions of
their state economies back to work my
hope is because again for me this is not
political
I'd want things to improve economically
and medically as quickly as is
reasonably possible some portions of
people are going to be getting back to
work hopefully things will take up a bit
or at least least continue taking down
less and reminder that the most
important takeaway here if we want to
take what's going on and turn it into
action for the long term we've got to
fix the problem now of course over the
long term the lesson here is even
economies that look really good by all
of the traditional indicators are really
real
we fragile our lack of preparedness has
been exposed here there will be more
pandemics there are going to be more
downturns we can't control that what we
can control is the underlying fragility
of our economic system and it's been
exposed as very very fragile Donald
Trump's press secretary Kaylee Megan
Annie as some are calling her McKenna
nee Mackin Annie I don't know how you
pronounce her last name but by that I
mean you personally but you know who I'm
talking about she could barely keep her
lies straight yesterday at a 26 minute
press briefing that she gave and we have
to come to the realization that they are
barely going to even try to hide their
wrongdoing at this point in time so when
she started doing these press briefings
I would livestream them and I would
sometimes say let's do an over under and
put it at three minutes will it take
Kaylee more than three minutes to tell
her first lie or less than three minutes
and she told a lie after like 20 seconds
so the next time I streamed one of her
press briefings I said let's do the
over-under at 20 seconds and then she
told the first lie within 12 seconds so
there's not even a point to doing that
anymore these are brazenly lie riddled
press briefings let's get into what
happened yesterday
when we learned yesterday that Donald
Trump tweeted threats to the governor of
Michigan about if you vote by mail I may
not send you a domani that you need
including for the recent flooding in
Michigan we knew that Caylee was going
to be asked questions about this and she
was and one of the questions was a good
one which is you know you've already
admitted that Trump talks to the
Michigan Governor regularly why tweet a
threat about vote-by-mail rather than
just communicate it directly Kaley
mcenany said that that's called
transparency yes yes
Kaley how often does the president talk
to director vote or acting director
Bullock
to to the Acting Director of OMB often
he just was in the Oval Office with the
president so they do speak often I don't
have a readout of the president's
schedule but they do speak regularly he
wanted to flag to him his concerns about
Michigan why don't he just tell him
instead of sending a tweet because the
President believes an unprecedented
transparency and I'm sure you as a
journalist Tom are very eager and
excited when you learn about the
president's decision-making process in
real time whether that's on Twitter for
me here up at the podiums you just said
that way that was the reasoning for
reasoning but I'm saying this is a
transparent president and I think that
that's something that you should be
allotting rather than questioning as to
why he decided to tweet this this is
truly a mix of 1984 and brave new world
and a totalitarian dictatorship where
facts simply don't matter war is peace
defeat is victory accusing a governor of
a crime on Twitter without evidence is
what they call unprecedented
transparency and good for the reporters
in the room I mean this is pretty
lukewarm praise but they kept asking
about this issue and Kaleigh kept doing
this move where she refers them to the
campaign you're that's really a campaign
issue you're gonna have to talk to the
2020 Trump campaign about that why is
she doing that because the question is
about something Trump said as president
about the disbursement of funds that he
manages as president why would that go
to the Trump campaign and also Kaley
mcenany herself is a lawyer nope that's
for the campaign which is basically a
way of saying go ask somebody else can
you tell us what law specifically the
president thinks state secretary
in Michigan broke by sending out the
applications and did the Secretary of
State in Georgia also break that law by
sending out applications for their fire
I referenced you to the campaign these
are ballot questions I referenced you to
the campaign is the president aware my
sermon employers the White House so
that's not a campaign question that's
the president saying that you have an
absentee ballot so I would refer you to
the campaign on that front and I would
note to you that many of those ballots
that are submitted via mail can be
fraudulent I cited to the bipartisan
study I can read it again maybe you
weren't paying attention when I read it
the first time so read it again
President Carter a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots were maimed the
largest source of potential voter fraud
so if you cast a ballot via mail and you
do so fraudulently that would be an
illegal act and I'd point you to that
and for further I'd point you to my
former employer which is the Trump
campaign also important I want to remind
you and I'm gonna become a bit of a
broken record on this vote by mail fraud
is mathematically non-existent yesterday
I gave you the numbers 250 million
people have voted by mail in the last 20
years there are seven to eight cases not
seven to eight percent there are seven
to eight cases of vote by mail fraud per
year there is way more in person voter
fraud of course there are more in person
ballots cast but those numbers also are
completely insignificant this type of
what I call retail strategy voter fraud
is essentially non-existent do not fall
for it now here's a really Orwellian
moment where Kaylie Mack and Annie was
asked about Susan Rice Susan Rice is
Barack Obama's former national security
adviser she recently a letter that she
wrote a memo that she wrote in 2017
which is exculpatory of Barack Obama in
the context of Obama gate was recently
released I told you about it yesterday
Caylee Mac and Annie does this thing
where she has a page in this notebook
with disinformation that she will turn
to whenever a question is asked that
even tangentially relates to something
she has in her book now that's fine
that's not I'm not criticizing her for
having notes
it's called being prepared it's
called research that's okay but the
thing is if Kaylie here's one word that
relates to her pages she will turn to
the page and read the page even if it
has nothing to do with the question and
in this case the name Susan Rice was
mentioned in a very specific exculpatory
context and Kaley turns to her Susan
Rice page and she reads two minutes of
unrelated attacks on Susan Rice sort of
sounds like she's arguing that Susan
Rice's letter was just a lie and I'm
actually going to play the full two
minutes for you normally I would I would
just slice out the key part but what you
really need to see Susan Rice's name is
mentioned Kaley turns to a page about
Susan Rice spends two minutes reading
unrelated things about Susan Rice and
then quickly ends the press conference
and leaves this is happening at almost
every single one of these press
conferences let's take a look
I apologize for subjecting you to two
minutes of this but it's important and I
know you brought up Susan Rice in that
context but I'm going to bring her up in
another context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified from Susan Rice on
Inauguration Day which is so peculiar
set the scene it's an odd Eurasian day
you're moving out of the White House
this is the most powerful building on
planet earth Susan Rice is moving out
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing her boxes
she's not being nostalgic about her time
in the White House what she's doing is
writing an email worth three times she
writes that President Obama emphasized
to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn by the book by the book by
the book she writes that three times as
a Shakespeare said thou doth protest too
much Susan Rice he didn't have the Susan
Rice part in there but I'll add that in
to she was asked specifically about the
unmasking and Michael Flynn after it
after she discussed it on January 5th in
the Oval Office with Obama after she
wrote this email to herself on
inauguration day she was asked by a good
journalist Judy Woodruff about this
email and she said about the unmasking
and Michael Flynn not the email but the
I'm asking she was asked specifically
about noon as his claim specifically so
many clarify was noon as it's claimed
and she said I know nothing about this
so it was a
and then Susan Rice since no one brought
it up to me I will bring it up to you
her attorney said that this was the
first opportunity three weeks after this
oval office meeting that she had to
write this email memorializing her Oval
Office meeting with a Barack Obama
discussing Michael Flynn it was her
first opportunity she said interesting
because she had an opportunity in those
three weeks On January 10th to do a
passing of the baton event with none
other than Michael Flynn where she
praised him wished him success and
talked about the great transition into
the White House and then on January 12th
she was able to participate in a story
that published on that date in the
lifestyle section of the Washington Post
so she never had time to write this
email until inauguration day as she's
rushing out the door when in fact she
had an opportunity to do all of those
things I'll leave that with you thank
you for bringing up Susan Rice not in
the context that I wished but for
allowing me to share that so the reason
I played all of that is that it's really
important for you to understand that
this is what they claim is radical
transparency and it's not of course it's
reading pre-planned talking points and
then walking off the stage before
anybody can say hey that stuff you just
said has nothing to do with my question
and the saddest part the most tragic
part of this is that Trump is slower
they think she's doing so well at her
job she doesn't answer questions she
does 20-minute press briefings
yesterday's was 26 minutes after showing
up 3040 minutes late that it's her
speech and her questions 26 minutes she
reads non-sequitur material from her
notes and then she leaves and the
trumpets are gleeful because to them
this counts a strength turning weird at
that like yesterday she turned a
question back on a reporter don't you
agree XYZ but that's not what a reporter
is there for lying barely keeping it
together attacking the media walking out
abruptly that's the state of affairs and
the trumpets are thrilled because they
believe she's owning the liberal media
we live in a very very backwards country
right now let me remind you monday is
Memorial Day we will be doing a one-day
huge membership special if you've been
thinking
about getting a membership membership of
course the number one way to support our
show Monday is a perfect day to do it
from spawn call wasn't perfect Monday is
the perfect day to get yourself a
membership if you want to be notified
about the Monday special just get on my
mailing list at david pakman.com the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink as' to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back today's new
members of the day are Jesse Leake and
Lowell Steiger Jesse and Lowell thank
you for your support also a big THANK
YOU to George Soares who is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
membership is step one staying a member
for almost five years is step two and
George has done it thank you so much
grab a membership at join pakman.com
let's check out some of the interesting
discussions on the david pakman show
reddit the david pakman show read it now
has a we are within striking distance
let me put it that way of twenty
thousand subscribers one of the largest
progressive independent media subreddits
out there go to david pakman.com slash
read it to find it a user named dismal
structure posted some polling about how
well joe biden is doing in arizona
florida and georgia now while it is true
that there is one poll that has biden up
one in Georgia but Biden is on average
down seven or eight points in Georgia
I don't consider Georgia a battleground
state I don't really consider it in play
but that could change Arizona and
Florida we've been talking about a lot
and are really really important signals
about how the November election could go
but I just want to reiterate I have no
problem looking at polls I have no
problem reporting on polls to you what I
am cautious of is I don't want anybody
to see a poll in their state that looks
good for Biden and to say Biden's got it
in the bag I don't need to vote so the
the reason I've only been talking about
these polls sparingly is I'm trying to
be responsible and avoid any action that
might suppress the vote by getting
someone to say I don't need to go out
there and vote so I will of course tell
you what the polling is looking like and
we've been doing it I appreciate it
being posted to the subreddit but we
should consider polling a possible
snapshot today in May and not
representative of what is certain to
happen in November and everybody's got
to go out and vote here's kind of a
funny post from Brody Mulligan Brody
says should we outlaw endless free
endless pasta and free refills the
coronavirus disproportionately kills
people who are obese people who are
obese are more likely to partake in
endless shrimp endless pasta or free
refills we can use public health
justification to crack down should we
listen here's the thing I when I was
like nine I went to Ponderosa in
Northampton Massachusetts and would love
just going up to the buffet endlessly
when I was 17 I once went to will now
Olive Garden and they'll just keep
bringing your bread straight breadsticks
if that's what you want it's obviously
not a good thing
we know from looking at the work of food
psychologists that it encourages
overeating it causes overeating I don't
know if Brody is literally serious about
banning and listen endless pasta but one
of the things I think we have to
consider is while I'm sure Brody's
instincts are coming from a very good
place a lot of these things will
disproportionately hit poorer people
there's I would venture a guess that
folks more likely to patronize places
with a buffets or unlimited this or that
are disproportionately likely to be
folks with less money and so in the same
way that I understand why we we might
say 63 million people voted for Trump we
need some kind of a test in order to be
allowed to vote that's the type of stuff
that will disproportionately hit poor
people if it also when it comes to
voting I think would be unconstitutional
so I get the instinct Brody but I think
we may end up causing new problems if we
do that and we want to bear that in mind
lastly we talked about this on the bonus
show this week Donald Trump keeps saying
that there's a cost to staying closed
for example suicides would go up I've
not yet seen data from the United States
about that but what we know in Japan is
that suicides are actually down as the
lockdown has removed a lot of the
stressors associated with daily life we
know that commuting to jobs is one of
the most stressful and least pleasant
things for people to do we know that
work culture is a very stressful anxiety
causing thing for people to do and
suicides are down in Japan during the
lockdown now it's important to mention
the US isn't Japan Japan
stereotypically known for a particularly
toxic work culture I'm not saying the
exact same thing would happen in the US
but when Trump offhandedly throws
something out as if it's an absolutely
foregone conclusion
suicides will be up if we're locked down
there are at least anecdotally Americans
who are actually better off because
they're preferring to work from home
they have eliminated a lot of the
cultural stresses of being at worked the
commuting etc it needs to be researched
and I'm sure you all know this don't
assume that because Trump says something
it's necessarily true join the
discussion on the subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t so three and
a half weeks ago I did a story for you
guys called doctor foul Qi has been
disappeared from Trump's briefings that
was nearly a full months ago and at the
time we were seeing signals of what was
to come get the doctors the hell out of
the way stop talking about death stop
talking about masks and people doing the
stuff that they need to do simply start
talking about reopening and this is when
I told you back of three and a half
weeks ago that Trump was no longer going
to have doctors at briefings he would be
shifting away from daily medical
briefings where media get to talk to
doctors look doctor foul she and dr.
Burks they're just going to talk about
the economy it's gonna be like the
disease is over they are going to
normalize the coronavirus deaths not
only did that happen
doctor foul Qi has been disappeared from
an interviews on television as well he
has not been seen since I believe it was
May 4th there was a while where doctor
foul Chi was pulled off of Trump's
briefings but he was still doing regular
television interviews no more pouchy has
been conspicuously absent from TV for
more than two weeks now it is completely
utterly obviously clear that this is
part of a concerted effort to make it
seem like the virus part of the pandemic
is over now of course you know this
isn't true we fortunately started to see
sort of a slow decline in new cases and
that's of course very
good deaths have been kind of up and
down if you look at a moving average as
we call it they've also been on a
decline that's all really really good
news but this is still a pandemic we
still have no effective treatment
we are still months from a vaccine we
are still shut down in a significant
portion of state economies but the
doctors are gone you just don't see them
anymore doctor foul his last TV
interview again I believe was May fourth
that's two and a half weeks ago he's
been missing since and I need you to
understand that this is not a
coincidence he is missing not because
nobody wants to interview him anymore
media want to talk to doctor foul Chi
he's been pulled now some of you might
wonder wasn't foul Chi on a modified
quarantine after he was exposed to
people at the White House who tested
positive for corona virus that shouldn't
stop him from doing interviews doctor
foul Chi was regularly doing interviews
by videoconference before he testified
before the Senate via videoconference
that is not the reason why doctor foul
Chi is no longer on TV if there was ever
a week to have doctor foul Chi on TV it
would be dipped this week good results
from a vaccine trial he works for the
NIH which is working in partnership with
these private industry private companies
developing a corona virus vaccine this
is just short of North Korean style
propaganda we've got a 100-year global
pandemic that's ravaging the economy our
economy in the global economy obviously
you put fast-food CEOs on TV instead of
an infectious disease doctor and the
other night on CNN they said we are no
longer going to be allowed to interview
doctor foul Chi and dr. Burks the White
House is no longer allowing them to do
interviews on CNN anymore now you could
say well CNN is fake news obviously
they're not going to be fair well
they're not being allowed to do
interviews anywhere and this is such a
common technique it's called hide the
facts there's an article from earlier
this month in The Guardian from
economist Robert Reich and he wrote
about Trump's four-step plan to reopen
the United States and the four steps are
start removing income support so people
have no choice but to return to work 112
check unclear that there's going to be
another check at this point in time
check they're doing it number to hide
the facts and that's what we're talking
about today that's where doctor foul
chief it's in this is where Florida not
releasing cause of death fits in hide
the facts number three pretend that it's
all about freedom and you know
patriotism and liberty they're doing
that and then number four Robert rice
wrote about this nearly a month ago
shield businesses from lawsuits for
spreading the infection by opening too
early all week Donald Trump has been
talking about how he wants to see that
made a reality we're a backwards country
we need to be hearing more from doctors
not less we do not need to be hearing
from fast-food CEOs Trump did I covered
it live and I it was disgusting Trump
did a whole roundtable earlier this week
with restaurant people and they also
found a psychiatrist
willing to say we've got to reopen the
economy now that that's an entire other
story they have now been looking for
random doctors willing to say my medical
opinion is we should open or open her up
and let it rip they did find one earlier
this week but they're hiding the truths
the truth they are hiding doctor foul
Chi and instead they're bringing you
know the the CEO of a chicken joint to
talk about how important it is that we
get back open it is ugly and it is
bordering on the type of propaganda that
typically we see from totalitarian
countries places where you have a real
authoritarian Trump's a wannabe
authoritarian he is very quickly
becoming a real one that includes hiding
the facts here later on we will talk
about Donald Trump's threats to States
over vote-by-mail plans really really
ugly dangerous stuff we'll continue
covering this and other stories from
today's program on the David Pakman show
Instagram follow us at david pakman show
on instagram and follow me at david
pakman
we got about little old me the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today John Barry who is author of the
book the great influenza the story of
the deadliest pandemic in history also
professor at Tulane University's School
of Public Health and Tropical Medicine
John so great to have you on thanks so
we've heard a number of different
assertions made about the flu pandemic
of 1918 from the President and from
others sort of in the context of
coronavirus let's just figure out a
little bit more about that what are the
origins of that pandemic well no one
knows for certain like cope in nineteen
and animal virus pollen torrents of
viruses have their natural reservoir and
birds but they can infect mammals an
animal virus some species to humans
spread around the world
infected about a third of the world's
population and killed 50 to 100 million
people adjusted for population that
would equal about 220 to 440 million
people today so fortunately as bad as
Kovan 19 is it's it's not nearly as
lethal as a 1918 pandemic what was the
sort of full duration as we understand
it of that pandemic well it really in
total covered from the spring of 1918
until the fall of 1920 however 2/3 of
the deaths perhaps more than two-thirds
of the deaths occurred in a 14 or 15
week period in the fall
19:18 the first wave was very spotty
miss we're not really sure exactly but
my guess is it although is pretty
widespread in Western Europe and in US
army camps in the spring it probably
missed most of this country and most of
the world then a I think the virus
mewing I'll so mild there were medical
journal articles that said this looks
and smells like influenza but it's not
killing enough people so it's probably
not influencing that turned around very
rapidly the virus mutated and then you
started seeing scientists saying this
looks and smells like influenza but
we've never seen in influenza that
killed like this although it was of
course in that second way as I said 14
to 15 weeks from mid September through
most of December then there was a third
wave in late winter in in early spring
of 1919 so it's very unusual to have two
waves of influenza in the same influenza
season very unusual so the virus had
mutated again I guess then in 1920 it
came back and that was pretty much it
that the virus probably mutated further
toward vileness and in addition our
immune systems having seen it several
times began to deal with it more
efficiently so it gradually became
seasonal influenza do you know the
president often refers to 1917 when
talking about that pandemic I have to
ask him okay yeah there's no there's
nothing been your understanding I have
history
nothing scientifically or
epidemiologically that would just
by going in 1917 you know my guess that
he said it once and he doesn't like to
admit any error over even the tiniest
things
so rather than correct himself in future
he just kind of wrapped his arms around
it as he seems to do with other mistakes
fair yeah in terms of the name often
called the Spanish flu can you talk
about number one why it has that name
but also sort of the early hot spots
that we often think about as the places
where it really started to spread I most
likely explanation for the name is that
Spain was not at war the warring
countries censored the press I didn't
like to print anything that was negative
that might hurt morale that might hurt
the war effort Spain wasn't at war plus
the king got sick celebrity culture then
is now so the Spanish press wrote about
it and other newspapers around the world
wrote about it and picked up the name
Spanish Influenza except in Spain where
they called it other things
the first known eruption was actually in
January in rural Kansas of southwest
corner of the state and in early
February we see it in New York City you
know it hit the army camps in first and
Camp Funston in Kansas for dryly in
early March spread to about half of the
army camps in the United States during
the spring seemed to travel with the US
troops to Europe although would have
gotten there anyway as I said it was in
New York and almost certainly other
places even before the army camp so it
would have spread eventually but the US
troops did seem to bring it to Europe in
late March and April they accelerated
this
and you know it
so he said earlier widespread in Western
Europe ludendorf the German commander
launched an offensive to try to win the
war before American soldiers arrived in
large numbers he blamed an outbreak of
influenza among his troops for the
failure of that offensive
of course I think that's looking for an
excuse there was influence on the other
side of the trenches as well although
the first known cases were in January in
rural Kansas the scientific community
thinks that the and it is possible that
it actually started there but and I
advanced that hypothesis in my book but
there's been a lot of work since my book
came out originally in 2004 and I myself
had backed off the Kansas hypothesis I
think it's more likely it started in
China other other hypotheses some very
good virologists think it started in
France Viet Nam's the possibility and
you never know it could have been New
York City most neurologists think that
it was circulating for at least a year
perhaps learning how to better infect
humans and in some think it was
circulating for a couple years so again
we'll never know where it actually did
start that spring waving was spotty and
mild in July the first widespread
outbreaks of the lethal second wave were
noted in Switzerland
fact it was it was so bad in Switzerland
US military intelligence report said
that this is being called influenza but
it's actually the Black Plague of the
Middle Ages mmm
wasn't it was influenza when it when it
couldn't sue the obviously medicine was
very different at that time
international travel was different at
that time media was different at that
time when it comes to mitigation what
was it that was done you know we talk
about the quarantines and the shutdowns
are unprecedented and in a sense they
are but there there were also some of
these techniques applied back then
exactly most cities in the United States
not quite all of them but very close to
all of them
closed all sorts of things they weren't
actually quite as Extreme as what we've
done they closed places public gathering
schools etc most of them did it too late
to have maximum impact just as I think
in the United States we closed down too
late to have maximum impact as we're
speaking there was a study from Columbia
University that came out today that said
if we close down a week earlier we would
have saved more than one third of the
live set of law have been lost so far
and if we closed down two weeks earlier
we would have saved about 60% of the
lives that have been lost so far similar
things happened in 1918 most cities
closed down too late to have maximum
impact when we think about the
communication that we now see of federal
and state guidelines here augmented by
television radio internet social media
etc how was it in 1918 through 1920 that
most people were learning about what was
supposed to be done to stop the spread
well of course
print was the only media you didn't even
have radio yet you had rumor and you had
print we were in a different situation
than because of the war the government
the Wilson administration focused
everything on winning the war they
passed a law which made it punishable by
20 years in prison
to quote Otto right print or publish any
disloyal profane scurrilous or abusive
language about the form of government in
the United States so you could curse
some action the government took and you
just broke the law truth was not a
defense this law was prosecuted
vigorously congressman was sentenced to
more than ten years in prison for this
law it's also the one that a couple of
memorable phrases came out of a Supreme
Court decision which actually upheld it
Oliver Wendell Holmes who has generally
considered a signal you know real
upholder of freedom of speech actually
wrote the opinion upholding this law and
he used a phrase clear and present
danger in his opinion along with the
analogy you can't shout fire in a
crowded theatre to justify upholding
this law anyway that was important
because and also the government had
created a propaganda arm and the
architect of that what was called the
committee for Public Information I wrote
that
nothing an experience teaches us that
truth is superior to falsehood the value
of an idea lies in its inspirational
value it matters very little if it is
true or false so on the one hand the
government was lying to people in order
to keep morale up for the war on the
other hand they were threatening people
with 20 years in the can for telling the
truth if the truth seemed critical of
the government so influenza fell into
that infrastructure
National Public Health leaders
associated with the government said
things like this is ordinary influenza
by another name or you have nothing to
fear if proper precautions are taken
neither of those statements were true
but they were echoed in most places
around the country many you know not
just echoes but quoted verbatim in in
most studies so initially people were
led to believe this was ordinary
influenza by another name but it didn't
take long
we're talking about almost a matter of
days before they realized this was
something very different I wish we had
more time to dig into it further but I
do want to make sure people know the
book is the great influenza the story of
the deadliest pandemic in history and
we've been speaking with the book's
author John Berry from Tulane University
a John I so appreciate your time
you're very welcome the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
if you for a moment believes that Donald
Trump's authoritarian tendencies were
all fun and games it has just become
very very real as Donald Trump is now
publicly threatening to withhold money
from Michigan if they decide to vote by
mail and also threatening the state of
Nevada over vote-by-mail so in the last
three to four weeks as coronavirus has
been raging vote-by-mail logically has
become a really big deal when we think
about we've got a presidential election
we have 35 Senate elections in November
when we think about people voting when
we think about voter disenfranchisement
we immediately talk about vote-by-mail
and that's been a growing conversation
for the last month or so Donald Trump
doesn't want you to vote by mail because
he knows that if more people vote it's
very very bad for him that's it's plain
and simple I mean we we can go into more
about it but that's the story Trump
knows more people voting is not good for
him in November he sees the polls and he
knows he needs any voter suppression
tactic he can get he has couched it as
vote-by-mail makes fraud easier this is
something we've debunked 250 million
ballots have been cast by mail in the
last 20 years on average there are seven
or eight individual issues of vote by
mail fraud per year that's not seven or
eight percent that's not seven or eight
per state that's seven or eight issues
per year nationally with absentee
ballots it is statistically as close to
zero as you can get well Donald Trump is
now becoming an authoritarian nightmare
that we always feared he would be when
it comes to this issue tweeting
yesterday quote Michigan sends absentee
ballot applications to seven point seven
million people ahead of primaries and
the general election this was done
illegally and without authorization by a
rogue Secretary of State I will ask to
hold up funding to Michigan if they want
to go down this voter fraud path now
there's a couple really important things
to understand here one is in the tweet
Trump says Michigan is doing something
illegal
by sending absentee ballot applications
earlier in the day Trump tweeted
chickens doing something illegal by
sending people absentee ballots now
that's not what Michigan is doing and
the michigan governor corrected him
Trump deleted the tweet replaced it with
an identical identical one that says
it's illegal to send everybody an
absentee ballot application why do we
care about that detail the reason we
care about it is because of the rules
that Michigan has now I really want to
be very clear about this there would not
be anything illegal in the way Trump is
claiming about sending everybody an
absentee ballot but it would go away go
against Michigan's established rules for
absentee ballots the rules are you need
to request one
you can't just be sent an absentee
ballot so importantly Michigan is
sending everybody an application for an
absentee ballot they want to vote in
person presumably but we as far as the
plan is right now they would still be
able to do it if they don't want to vote
in person they can submit their request
for an absentee ballot and they would be
sent one there is nothing illegal about
that now Caylee Mackin Annie Trump's
press secretary was asked multiple times
during yesterday's press briefing Trump
used the word illegal what exactly is
the law that's being broken she said go
talk to the Trump campaign which of
course makes absolutely no sense at all
it's not just Michigan where Donald
Trump is doing this Trump also tweeting
about Nevada quote state of Nevada
thinks that they can send out illegal
vote-by-mail ballots creating a voter
fraud scenario for the state and the US
they can't if they do I think I can hold
up funds to the state sorry but you must
not cheat in elections this is not
cheating okay this is a ruse and Donald
Trump is creating a virulent SiC army of
ignorant trumpets
who are just repeating these talking
points without even understanding them
it's illegal to do this vote by mail is
a fraud I really need people to
understand the primary crux of this
story we have states rights in this
country
listen to me sounding like a
conservative Trump touts federal
federalism means states rights
federalism means anything that the
federal government doesn't specifically
have a duty to do the power to do it is
by default the power of the states to
decide for themselves
we don't have one federal election in
the United States for president we have
a bunch of states each runs their own
election that's the Constitution that's
federalism there is nothing here that
would allow the federal government to
dictate how a state runs their election
there now if you have truly a
constitutional issue of
disenfranchisement or something like
that you might see a case be appealed
all the way to the Supreme Court but
this is Trump's wannabe dictator coming
out Michigan allows for absentee voting
for any reason ever since 2018 that
passed 66 with a 66% majority it's in
the state constitution this is
federalism this is the law Michigan is
having major flood issues right now
Trump is essentially threatening
people's lives by saying I won't send
you money if you do vote by mail and
that is of course a decision that
Michigan is one hundred percent allowed
to make outside the United States
they are watching this in horror I got
an email from a viewer in Europe saying
David isn't this fascism Trump is
attacking the sovereignty of a state
voting system that is enshrined in
federalism they are allowed to make
decisions about how they will vote what
is happening to the United States I wish
I could tell you it is a tragedy it is a
nightmare and I hate to say it but once
again I don't know that Trump will be
held accountable for these threats in
any way other than other than if we vote
him out in November let's continue our
discussion about Donald Trump and voting
and vote by mail Republicans are not
even pretending to hide their desire to
suppress turnout in November why
Republicans know lower turnout is better
for them it's it you know sometimes we
have to get into the weeds and explain
this that they just know it's better for
them for fewer people to vote Donald
Trump also by the way vote-by-mail
creates a paper trail which they don't
want it makes it more difficult to
disenfranchised people they don't want
any of this stuff right Donald Trump has
been ranting and raving against
vote-by-mail for more than a month snap
month now in the last week we've seen
this full-court press from him and from
his press secretary and from others
Donald Trump threatening to withhold
money from States if they do
vote-by-mail as I already told you
Michigan and Nevada and now Donald Trump
used this word honor again when talking
about suppressing votes
you might remember earlier this week
Donald Trump said it was an honor to
have the most coronavirus cases in the
world that was really weird
here's video of Trump again arguing
against vote by mail saying voting is an
honor now in reality voting is a right
but let's take a listen to what Trump
said common sense we tell you that it's
massive manipulation can take place
massive they and you do you have cases
of fraudulent ballots where they
actually print them and they give them
to people to sign maybe the same person
signs them with different writing
different pens I don't know as a lot of
things can happen now if you can you
should go and vote voting is an honor it
shouldn't be something where they send
you a pile of stuff and you send it back
voting is an honor it shouldn't be
something where they send you a pile of
stuff Donald Trump says they send you a
ballot the same ballot you would get at
the ballot box and they send you an
envelope in which you return that ballot
it's not a pile of stuff now what's
fascinating is that what Trump is
describing is is number one a terrible
way to win an election and number two
it's something that it's exclusively
Republicans who have been caught doing
it so there's the retail oh sorry I hit
my mic there there's the retail strategy
of voter fraud and then there's the
wholesale strategy of voter suppression
and election fraud so the retail
strategy is what Trump is talking about
you you know vote-by-mail is a way that
people could send in to ballots or you
know you vote harvesting or whatever the
case may be
terrible way to win elections and it
also doesn't happen seven to eight
instances of vote by mail fraud per year
statistically zero the whole sales
strategy is you suppress the vote you
buy election officials you reduce
turnout that
is actually the simpler and more
effective way of stealing elections so
the entire strategy Trump is describing
here you know duplicates and printing
ballots and all of this different stuff
it doesn't happen it doesn't happen 250
million absentee ballots have been cast
over the last 20 years and we have seven
to eight instances of so-called fraud
with those per year Trump again though
talking about fake ballots and the light
take a look well I think if we're
talking about the mail-in ballots if
people mail-in ballots is a lot of
illegalities they send in ballots that
they harvest ballots you know all about
harvesting and they do lots of bad
things ideally people go out and they
vote now if you need a mail-in ballot if
you need a specific like as an example
I'm in the white house and I have to
send the ballot to Florida that makes
sense
so if you need it for some reason or if
somebody's not well that's one thing but
when you send out 7.7 million men
mail-in ballots
there's forgeries there's frankly
duplication where they print ballots on
the same kind of paper with the same
kind of machinery and you can't tell the
difference and they sent in thousands
and thousands of fake ballots and I tell
you what this nation can't be going down
that path because it's a very dangerous
path to go down this is not a dangerous
path to go down it's a very advanced and
sophisticated path to go down ballot
harvesting which Trump talks about
that's something Republicans have been
caught doing and other than a couple of
instances of Republicans doing it we
don't know of any ballot harvesting that
turned any election I believe there was
a special election trying to think there
was one district in 2018 I don't
remember if it was a special I think it
was North Carolina I wish I had it in
front of me where this sort of funny
business from a Republican strategist
likely influenced the results or it
could have there are really no other
examples of it now on the other hand the
strategies that the right uses like
voter suppression closing down voting
places purging people from voter rolls
that is how you actually suppress the
vote
in order to win elections you know
double votes in person voter fraud
absentee ballot fraud doesn't win you
elections now let's talk about the
bigger picture just a little bit not
much good is likely to come from
coronavirus we can hope right we can
hope this will be a wake up call will
realize how fragile our economic systems
are and we will strengthen them we will
make them anti fragile to take a a
phrase from Nasim Nassim Nicholas Taleb
we might realize that we were totally
unprepared for a pandemic we'll get
better prepared for the next pandemic
and I don't know that that's really
going to happen
Trump disbanded the pandemic response
team from shouldn't have we didn't shut
things down quickly enough March 5th
would have been a perfectly reasonable
time to do it didn't happen
South Korea did it Taiwan did it New
Zealand did it there's a lot to learn I
don't know that we're gonna learn
anything there if we can move a bunch of
states to vote by mail it would be a
major advancement and maybe we can make
some progress there but this entire
voting is an honor thing don't be
tricked voting is a right period this
entire voting is an honor and it should
be done the way Trump likes its publicly
justifying voter suppression
specifically to get Donald Trump
re-elected Trump sees the polls Trump
publicly says Joe Biden has no shot but
we know Trump is scared Trump
two weeks ago furiously got on the phone
with his campaign manager Brad parse
kale and said how the hell am I losing
to Joe Biden Michigan could be key for
Donald Trump he's threatening Michigan
about vote-by-mail they are doing it in
broad daylight they have to be stopped
in one of the ways that we stopped them
is by ensuring that everybody votes in
November we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p here
is a caller who says i should stop
catering to stupid people take a listen
hey David I noticed that a lot of the
time now you preface your talking points
with well just so you know I'm gonna say
something george w bush said and was
reasonable right now Neil Cavuto said
that was reasonable but just remember
that doesn't mean I like Neil Cavuto
remember George W Bush is a war criminal
except [ __ ] who cares
if people can't separate a person
overall they're like what a person is
overall from them making a point that's
fair or reasonable from time to time if
everything is guilt by association with
these people who cares what they think
don't even practice the expect anymore
it's just dude these people are stupid
what do you guys think so what the
caller is referring to is for example
recently george w bush put out a totally
bland uncontroversial call for unity
around coronavirus and it you know
donald trump flipped out attacked him
and i said guys you know when when
george w bush sounds reasonable given
how terrible of a president he was you
know that things have gotten really
wacky
and people started tweeting me David
here normalizing you're rehabilitating
the reputation of war criminal george w
bush and i clarified a bunch of times
that's that's not what I'm doing my
views on george w bush haven't changed
he just despite being so bad he made
sense this one time should I just stop
the disclaimers I want to hear from you
let me know what you think we've got a
great bonus show for you today barbers
are cutting people's hair on the
Michigan Capitol lawn to protest the
coronavirus shutdowns we will talk about
yet another company touted by Trump
getting a very very fancy billion dollar
border wall construction contract
probably won't surprise some of you and
Michael Cohen Trump's former personal
attorney is going to be released from
prison all of those stories and more on
the bonus show and remember Monday
Memorial Day one-day membership special
huge membership discount you want to
take advantage on Monday get on my
newsletter at david patten.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blinka store free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink accom slash david pakman I've also
included the link right underneath this
video